ذكر الرئيس التركي بعد الساعات من الزلزال
الاخير بزلزال ارزنجان الذي ضرب شمال شرق
تركيا في ديسمبر عام
1939 وادى الى قتل
32,968 شخصا وخلف نحو 100 الف جريح في
فبراير عام 1960 ضرب زلزال المدمر مدينه
اغادير بالمغرب وقتل فيه 15 الف شخص واصيب
12 الفا اخرون وفي اكتوبر عام 1980 ضرب
زلزال ولايه الشلف في الجزائر فدمر
المدينه وقتل
3500 شخص بجانب عشره الاف مصاب اواخر عام
1982 وقع زلزال بمدينه ذمار شمال اليمن
وترك نحو 2800 قتيل
و1,500 اصابه
تعد ايران احدى اكثر البلاد تعرضا للزلازل
في المنطقه اسواؤها ضرب محافظتي جيلان
وزنجان منتصف عام 1990 وخلف ما لا يقل عن
خمسه وثلاثين الف قتيل ونحو 60 الف جريح
عام
1999 وقع زلزال مرمره الذي لا ينساه
الاتراك حتى اليوم حيث قتل نحو 17 الف شخص
وشرد نصف مليون في مايو 2003 ضرب زلزال
مدينه بومرداس الجزائريه وخلف
2266 قتيلا واكثر من عشره الاف اصابه
اواخر نفس العام وقع زلزال بمدينه في شرق
محافظه كرمان الايرانيه وادى الى مقتل
26,000
و271 شخصا واكثر من ثلاثين الف اصابه